-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Now I got to share
some of my favorite
airport-fail stories
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one
is from @BamaBeano.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-He says, "I was running lat
for a connecting flight
that was leaving in 5 minutes,
so I had to race
from gate A to gate G.
Halfway there, I realized
someone was yelling after me
"Run, Forrest, run!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-BamaBeano!
-This one's from @ColleenM
She says, "I was fiddling with
the side of my plane seat
and grasped something I though
was the recliner handle.
Then I realized they had decided
to stretch out behind me.
I had grabbed their bare foot.
-Oh!
-Oh! Oh!
-Ugh!
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @Deanna-MAD.
She says, "I took an edibl
while waiting at the airport
ended up missing my flight
on purpose
because I was too relaxed
and wanted to finish watchin
"The Great British Bake Off.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Hawa-- Hawaii
is not going anywhere."
-"Yeah, man." [ Laughs ]
-"Hawaii's not going anywhere.
-"Oh, ate a foot."
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @Le-Marz.
She says, "My brother and
were at a
self-check-in machine
when a woman behind us
asked for help.
After that, everyone thought
we were airport employees.
We were there for three hour
checking people into Toronto."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Uh, sure."
This one's from @WFord22.
He says, "I was walking
in the airport to my gate
when a little kid ran past m
yelling, "The poop
is coming out!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
-"Run, Forrest, run!"
[ Laughter ]
-Gate number 2.
[ Applause ]
This one's from @BohemianJenn.
She says, "A legit clown
once sat next to me on a plane
When we made eye contact,
he felt the need to assure m
that he was 'a good clown,
not a creepy clown.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Or is that what a creepy clown
would say to trick you
into thinking...
-Trick you.
-This one's from @Danielita89.
She says, "I fell asleep
during a long layover
and woke up to a little girl
poking me
and asking out loud,
'Mommy, is she alive?'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Leave the dead lady alone
sweetheart."
-"Don't touch her."
The last one is from
@KatyByrneDesign.
She says, "I once
sat next to a man
who slammed
two servings of nachos
right after takeoff.
Later, when the flight
hit turbulence,
he started yelling, "This
isn't going to end well!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it.
Those are our "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Alright, here are
some of my favorite
Worst Lie I Ever Told
tweets from you guys.
Um, this one's
from @TheFaithHam.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah.
-I got faith in ham.
-She says, uh,
"I would hide in the pantr
to eat candy
so my kids wouldn't see.
When they found me,
I told them
I had been praying."
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh! Oh!
That's not gonna be good.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This one's from @FERGet-it.
He says, "I once told my siste
there was a coin
between a nickel and a dim
called a 'dickel.'"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbals clash ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
-No, whoa!
-She believ--
-Hello!
-"She believed in 'dickels
for a week."
There you go.
-I've believe in dickels
all my life.
-"How many dickels is that?"
Yeah.
-Hmm!
-This is from @BelleofBabel.
She says, "I told
my niece and nephew
that it's illegal
to get married before 30
so they'd stop asking
why I'm not married."
Like, "Enough! Enough.
It's illegal."
-"I don't believe in dickels."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This one's from @MMMorganTX
She said, "I would spray
wiper fluid
as we passed the park
and tell my daughter
we couldn't go
because it was raining."
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's cold! That's cold!
-That's cold-blooded!
-That's ice-cold!
[ Laughter and applause ]
"It's raining.
I'd love to go on the seesaw
No way, no way, too wet."
-"I've got to watch my stories."
[ Laughter ]
-This one is from @RogerUSAF
He says, "I told my kids
that FAO Schwarz
was a toy museum
so they wouldn't ask me
to buy anything for them."
"No, no, now, don't touch.
Don't touch anything."
-"Look with your eyes."
[ Laughter ]
"Touch with your eyes. Come on."
-"It's a toy museum, yeah.
There's 30 Transformers --
the same one."
-"Those numbers are
the catalog numbers."
[ Laughter ]
-The last one is from
@EmilyOfCoursey.
She says, "Guy asked if
I remembered his name.
I'm like, 'Yeah, but
how do you spell it?'
He's like, 'T.J.'"
"Alright, huh?
You spell it like that?"
There's our "Tonight Show"
Hashtags.
Check out more of our favorite
through
tonightshow.com/hashtags.
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
Badvice tweets from you guys
This one's from
@MicahWilliams24.
He says, "Guy at work tried to
give me marriage advice
and finished with, 'Trust me
I've been married three times.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, then...
"That's
three times the experience."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @2OmarSC1.
Uh, sounds like he's
a robot or something, yeah
He says, "When someone
had a cold,
my grandma used to tell them
to drink tequila,
because, 'Either
you'll lose the cold
or you'll forget about it.'"
It's a good idea.
-That's good advice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ] This is good.
This is from @ShawnGet.
He says, "My grandpa
once told me
not to use my blinker
when driving
because, 'It's no one's business
where you're going.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Hey, mind your own business!"
-Yeah.
-This one's from
@britbrhodehouse.
She says, "I was told
to sprinkle baby powder
on my sheets
to 'freshen them up.'
I woke up looking
like a powdered doughnut."
[ Laughter and applause ]
You slept like a baby,
literally.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @ChelseyBunbun
[ Laughs ]
-ChelseyBunbun.
-No, this is a good one.
[ Laughter ]
She says, "My dad told me,
'If you have a bad cough,
take a laxative -- then
you'll be afraid to cough.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What?!
[ Laughter ]
-That's what I'm talking about
-That's why
they call her Bunbun.
-I don't know. [ Laughs ]
-Hmm! Slossen.
-Alright, this last one's
from @KellyGator.
She says, "Bought a car
that smelled like cigarettes
and was told vinegar
would fix it.
Now my car just smells
like pickled cigarettes."
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show" Hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags